You breathe in air.
It goes down there...
...into your lungs, yeah, you have a pair.
Now to your blood, the oxygen...
...the heart and muscle pumps it to your organs.
They couldn't do without each other 'cause your body acts as one system.
You eat some food.
It's tasting good.
Now down the tube to your stomach and small intestine...
...where it digests and passes through.
It's taken up by your veins and your arteries...
...to all the organs in your body that need some energy.
You stand up tall, you rarely fall...
...because there's bones inside it all.
Your skeleton is made of bones...
...and ligaments connect them all.
You know your body wouldn't stand up if you didn't have a skeleton.
Oh silly me, almost forgot...
...the most important little part.
It's in your head, controls it all.
It's called your brain,...
...if I recall.
Yes, your brain makes it all possible for you to live right now at all.